each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay everybody it's my pleasure today to
introduce to you Margaret brunette from
Oregon State University where she's a
full professor she visits us often and
we have many interactions with her and
her students funding them in their
research sometimes even hosting them
when they do their dissertation studies
and whatnot Margaret has been super
active in the area that bridges
programming and HCI and she has focused
for a long time now on gender and must
of her research and I'm sure which we'll
be talking about today has been done in
spreadsheets and understanding how to
work in spreadsheets it's fascinating
stuff and she's also been the chip a
pers chair for Chi she's been on the
steering committee for the visual
languages and human centered computing
conference forever so she's been super
active and has published a lot in this
area I'm sure she'll have lots to talk
to us about today so welcome Margaret
thank you Mary so for those of you here
and people remote I'm very happy to have
you all here today I want to talk about
gender HCI what about the software so
the idea is people have been very
interested in recent years about gender
differences that interact with the
workplace in software development with
education issues and software
development but what we've been
interested in is what about the software
itself what happens when somebody sits
down and faces a keyboard if they're
male versus being a female I want to so
that's what the talking about I want to
also give credit to my colleagues in the
uses consortium that's end users shaping
effective software so that's a group of
about 15 of us across eight or nine
different institutions depending on the
day you count who are working on
anything relating to end user
programming but a lot of us have a
particular focus on gender so and by the
way those institutions
is our oregon state where I am carnegie
mellon drexel penn state nebraska
cambridge IBM and university of
washington I didn't hear Microsoft in
that list just right now but course that
could change so okay here we go no why
am I talking to you today actually I'm
trying to get all of you involved so
today I want to describe what we've done
so far in trying to understand this
problem then i'll be here starting in
late march for three months on a
sabbatical visit and i'll be
collaborating with Mary who introduced
me and Shawn Zee iqbal and Cory Quinn
and Gina vinalia and so what we want to
do together is look at gender phenomena
and how people use Microsoft products
our research goal is to try to
generalize what we've done so far just
pretty much in the world of spreadsheets
and see just exactly how pervasive that
is a cross software product usage
especially software products they're
intended to help people solve problems
so problem solving is especially what
we're interested in so that's our
research goal but then a Microsoft goal
would be to produce better products for
males and females so what you could be
doing starting today or tomorrow or next
week through June is gather some data as
part of what you're already doing about
your team's products and if you pick up
gender to and start thinking a little
bit about some of the issues that I'll
be raising today then your product could
be helping could be getting some benefit
out of what we'll be doing together and
could be helping us to an understanding
how far our results really generalize so
I hope you'll get involved there are
these pieces of paper that are going to
be going around in which you don't it's
not a commitment but I'll get your name
and email address and your your team or
product that you're thinking about
perhaps contributing data to and what
kind of data you might imagine
contributing if it's okay with your team
and you your time permits and all that
kind of stuff so I hope you'll give me
that so that I'll have a way to get back
to you when i finally get here or if you
can't actually write it down today
a then you know you could send email to
any of us who are working together to
marry or Dashon zr2 tacori or to me and
and that would be great okay so that's
my involvement you can driven tribute
data about actually three things
existing features that you already have
in your product or if you're one of the
people who's been following this
research for a while you may already
have started to have some ideas about
what to change and if you actually
institute some sort of different feature
then then we could get old old product
versus new product which would be
wonderful the other thing we're working
on is strategies so if you could get
data about strategies and that would be
great too so I'm going to be going
through all three of those today and you
could be giving a surveys videotaped
interviews user studies stats whatever
it is you've got you could analyze it
first or not so we just want to connect
with you and whatever way would work
okay so why do we care there are two
reasons why we should really care about
gender and software the first is the
pipeline story so of course they're all
of these these these issues about women
in computer science but we think that
software is one of those issues that we
should think about because just imagine
you know supposing you come you know
you're a young girl you sit down in
front of a computer for the first time
to do something serious something of a
problem solving nature and it just isn't
a good fit for you you know what are you
going to do are you going to leave and
say boy I want to be a computer
scientist when I grow up no okay so so
there's a whole pipeline reason but
there's another reason that's perhaps
even more important regardless of
whether those those women would have
gone into computer science if their
experience were better you know
regardless of whether they were going to
be graphic designers or or business
analysts or accountants or whatever if
the software is limiting their success
there's this whole glass ceiling thing
that's going on and we don't want that
and in fact I'm going to tell you about
somebody named Ashley who had exactly
that thing
happen Ashley in high school had a
career plan to become a graphic designer
and went to college and majored in
graphic design but you know the thing is
in all these classes then you had you'd
splash and I don't know if any of you've
used flash in recent years but although
it started out being kind of WYSIWYG it
sort of turned into this Java like thing
mostly for software developers and then
web programming came up and so at that
point the major changed no longer in
graphic design but instead in art now
Ashley was very bright in fact before
graduating actually got one of these
really top awards at that University for
being one of the top academic students
in the whole University so this is not a
matter of a stupid person so why is this
well perhaps the software was just not a
good match to Ashley's problem-solving
style learning style confidence
information processing style and so on
and that's what we think so what we've
been doing to try to study this is we've
been starting by reading the literature
about theories that relate to gender
differences in things like problem
solving style information processing
style self-efficacy all those kinds of
things and from those we derive specific
hypotheses which we go to the lab and
refined tests try to understand
empirically we use those results to
redesign prototypes and evaluate them
and that gives us new ideas about
theories refinements of the theories new
variants for our our our whole set of
hypotheses and we go around the circle
again and again and again so there are
three things that I want to focus on
today as I alluded to earlier one of
them is we want to know is there
something broken our their gender
differences in future usage and I'll
tell you about that then we want to know
what can we fix it at the feature level
can we make featured changes that might
help to reduce the gender gap and then
the third one is looking deeper weather
there are things that we can't fix at
the feature level unless we go deeper
and really start thinking about the
problem solving strategies the males and
females might be trying to use so first
feature usage is there something broken
now this is the most mature of the
things we've been working on so we've
been at it for quite a while I'm going
to give you a whirlwind tour of five
studies obviously we won't be going into
a lot of depth on all five of these the
first one was qualitative we were
looking at feature interest within took
that to a statistical lab study to see
if we could find some statistical
differences in feature usage and
self-efficacy then we did a qualitative
follow on then we did another
statistical study in which we looked at
the ties of what we'd found before with
feature usage to tinkering and finally
we did another statistical study that
was actually hosted here at Microsoft in
which we looked to see how our previous
studies which were in our own prototype
spreadsheet system generalized to excel
a commercial system okay study number
one feature interest so when we began we
wondered from reading the the
theoretical literature whether we might
see some differences in the amount males
and females we're actually using various
features in spreadsheets and we had a
lot of fun we had a bunch of old data we
spread it out all over the floor we had
a profile that looked like these for
every single user actually the profiles
were more complicated than this they had
lots of different colors in them and so
on and so forth but this one's
particularly telling and what we would
do is we sorted them out and then we'd
look at the back of the piece of paper
to see if it was a male or female and
sometimes we said oh my gosh look at
this everybody in this pile is a male
and so so one of the things we found out
is that there was this tremendous
difference in the amount the males were
using these features up here is a count
and down here is time okay versus the
amount the females were using the
features as I said this is just to users
but these are fairly representative so
anyway from this old data we formed some
hypotheses
and went to the lab for a statistical
study one of the things we also got out
of the literature was that there might
be a potential tie between this feature
usage and self-efficacy self-efficacy is
a specific form of self-confidence it's
regarding a specific task so your
confidence in your ability to perform a
specific thing like debug this
spreadsheet it's a general theory it's
been found to be very predictive a
willingness to try perseverance and so
on and so forth and in the past
literature we learned the females
traditionally had lower computer
self-efficacy than males so we thought
this might be an important factor and we
went to the lab with this research
prototype of a spreadsheet system which
I'll explain to you in a minute and the
task that we set forth for our users was
to find and fix errors in spreadsheet
formulas and the reason we used our
prototype in this one instead of Excel
is that we have some specific features
that we had previously designed to help
with exactly that task so here are the
features we divided them into three
categories first there was the familiar
type everybody knows how to edit
formulas or at least everybody in our
study did because we made sure they had
prior spreadsheet experience in our
prototype you do it with a text box
instead of the way you do it in Excel
but it's still a very familiar way of
doing things then also we taught them
two features and a little tutorial at
the beginning we knew that none of them
had any experience with these features
because they're unique in our prototype
and one of them is a check mark so if
you happen to notice that a value is
correct you can check it off and if you
do that under the hood the system is
making calculations about how thoroughly
tested your spreadsheet is using a
formal test adequacy criterion and and
it does that behind the scenes and then
what it does in front of the scenes is
it takes the cell borders and colors
them along a continuum from red to blue
blooming being more tested more testing
coverage so that check mark actually
turned this cell all the way blue and
this one it tested partially according
to our criteria so that made it
purple so that was one thing we taught
them we didn't tell him about test
adequacy criteria we just sort of gave
them kind of the night naive version of
that and then also there are these data
flow arrows which you can pop up and
those data flow arrows do what you would
expect but in addition they also have
the tested pneus coloring here so you
can see that the interaction between
these two is also fully tested because
it's blue so we taught them that and
then there was one other feature that we
did not teach them the X so instead of
noticing that a value is right you might
notice that it's wrong in which case you
can exit out and if you do that the
system reasons about which formula may
have actually been at fault for that
because it might not be the one here and
color eise's these highlights them in
darker and darker shades of yellow
depending on how implicated it thinks a
cell is so those were the features in
these three categories familiar taught
and on top oh and there was a little
tooltip thing too so they could explore
any feature they wanted to taught or on
top with this tool tip stuff okay so
what we find out first notice this
lovely 45 degree line we've found this
in study after study after study this is
feature effective feature count and this
is self-efficacy okay we always get this
the lower the self-efficacy for females
the higher the lower the use of more
advanced features the effective use of
more advanced features as their self f2c
efficacy goes up so does their feature
usage look at the guys they're all over
the place look at this pv p value flip a
coin okay i mean they're they're a low
self-efficacy men and their I felt
self-efficacy man but it has no
relationship ought to whether or not
they use features yes
undergraduate students or do you mean
hall people throughout population so
this particular study was undergraduate
students not computer science majors
we're not allowed to have very much
computer science background either and
many of our studies have been business
students only I can't remember if this
particular one was in a couple of our
other studies we went beyond those age
groups and in fact the one that was
sponsored by microsoft in excel was not
students but we haven't gotten to study
number five yet but we always find this
this this graph every single study we
find this yes that was thought that was
taught was it least advertised
um we're marginally uh we said and you
know and you can see there's also this x
mark so we just sort of tossed it out
there but we didn't say you should be
using this you know we just tossed it
out there and of course they knew that
they had tooltips available over
everything because that came up in the
tutorial so the bottom line here is that
self-efficacy mattered but it's not just
about self-efficacy it's it impacted
females differently than males okay so
what about trying new features just
touching them well so this is the time
they first touched something look at the
females they were much faster to start
with the familiar feature namely editing
formulas the guys were later type taught
females are much later at even touching
the types of features we we taught them
look at the untaught feature okay I mean
okay so bottom line the females ventured
to try out new features much later than
the males what about genuine engagement
we had a way of measuring whether people
were really following up on things were
that they were trying out so for the
males type taught they were much more
engaged for the females type familiar
they were much more engaged for the
untaught significantly more males use
the untaught features than the females
bottom line the females engaged in the
new features less than the males okay so
let's get to the chase here the goal was
to fix bugs in that study so how'd they
do there with the seed bugs that were
fixed there was no difference with
however the females were significantly
more likely to introduce new bugs that
had not been there okay so let's think
about this a minute maybe they're just
stupid right they just in a room okay is
that what happened well there's only one
way to introduce a new bug how do you do
it mechanically any ideas
you can edit a formula that's right what
are the female spending all their time
doing editing the formulas okay the
males were using all of these other
features to help them problem-solve too
so they were just spending less time in
this way to introduce bugs furthermore
there was this kind of self-fulfilling
prophecy going on so in our study the
females had significantly lower self
efficacy than the males and this was as
you've seen tied to their future usage
not true of the males so we asked one of
the things that we had on our post
session questionnaire was if you didn't
use this feature of that feature why not
and the females were significantly more
likely to say because I thought it would
take me too long to learn them but in
fact we also had a comprehension test at
the end on how these various features
work what would happen if you did this
or that or the other there was no
difference in their comprehension of the
features even though throughout the
course of the task the men were getting
a lot more practice with them there was
still no difference in comprehension
furthermore we also know that using
these features helps we know in this
study and in several other ones that the
the use of these features does help you
to find and fix bugs yes Andy ask your
question Sarah of you bugs introduced
yeah does that number normalized by how
much actual time
no no this is just raw new bugs
introduced just like when you're coding
when when you're coding the more lines
you turn the more likely you're going to
introduce boxes exactly the more time
you spend anything formulas the more
likely it is you're going to introduce a
budget so far gone that's right why is
that then you can see they're females
are more likely to introduce bugs that
males independent of the time that they
spend editing for everything formulas
well i would argue i would argue that
I'd rather know it this way than your
way because what we really want to know
is is the collection of features
available to them and the way they're
using that type more likely to lead them
down this this bad path and so that's
what that's what this set of numbers
tells us yeah okay let's see here I
think I polished this one off alright so
basically not using the features with
pretty much tying one hand behind their
backs okay then we did another study
qualitative in which we had users talk
aloud as they found and fix errors in
the spreadsheet and here is one low
self-efficacy user telling us how she
regards these wonderful features of ours
what's this little arrow doing they're
everywhere so I need to take this oh my
goodness now what's happening too much
happening ok so this user was not
entranced with our features here's
another one this is a different feature
which you haven't seen in something
called guards guards are kinda sorta
related to excels data validation thing
so you can provide a range that
expresses the values within which a cell
should fall so this emails using them
she's very production-oriented here she
says so 0 to 100 is the guard I'm
entering ok ok hmm so it doesn't like
the minus 5 they can get a 0 that that
gets rid of the angry red circle so you
can see that she's she's businesslike
production-oriented her motivation is to
use these exactly the way we designers
intended her to use them to solve these
bugs
yeah there's this circle let's there's
this circle yeah but she's making it
Angry yeah all right now here's what the
mail says he starts down the same path
she does the first thing I'm going to do
is go through and check the guards for
everything just to make sure none of the
entered values are above or below any of
the range is specified so homework 1
actually I'm going to put book guards on
everything because I feel like it I
don't even know if this is really
necessary but it's fun okay it's fun but
then look what happens he gets into it
for the fun of it and then it starts
doing him some good so okay it doesn't
like my guard apparently okay aha the
reason I couldn't get the guard for the
sum to be correct is because the sum
formula is wrong okay so they both got
benefit but the male thought it was fine
so this caused us to start thinking
about tinkering we said okay so you know
the guys you know there they kind of
like to play around with this stuff so
we did a study very similar to the
previous one first let's think about
let's look at what happened with the
females for the females increased
tinkering was good okay if they did it
it led to more effective use of these
features which we call percent tested
pneus measure that way and that in turn
was predictive of bugs fixed ok so for
females tinkering was good for them for
males testing effectiveness the features
were good for bugs fixed but the
tinkering was not tied to more use
effective use of the features so this is
kind of strange the male's tinkering was
maybe not the world hugest advantage
here ah so in fact ultimately increased
tinkering was inversely predictive of
the bugs fixed because of this bit right
here okay why well there were two things
that went on the first was pausing the
male's tended to not pause the females
did when they tinkered they tinkered
pause fully okay
now the education literature says that
pauses improve critical thinking and our
results showed that in fact the pauses
mid tinker tink or like that instead of
ten particular okay tank / was
predictive of understanding and
effective use of the problem-solving
features why number two well we had two
environments in that study the low-cost
environment that you've seen I've shown
this to you in previous slide so you
click here and you get it here you click
here and it goes away very easy very low
cost to tinker for the other environment
that we had I'll tell you a little bit
more about this but suffice it to say
right now it was a little more complex
and tinkering was not so easy look at
the females doesn't matter which
environment they're in the amount of
tinkering they do is about the same
either way maybe it's because of the
possible way they did it for the male's
however look at this huge difference
okay now the difference between these
features and that feature is not really
that huge and let yet look at this huge
difference in the Mail's here they're
obsessive and they're tinkering here
their level of tinkering is it the same
level that turned out to be good for the
females okay so we've got this sort of
tinkering obsession thing going on with
the males all right so one more quick
study and then on we go to to the next
topic we then tried to replicate
replicate this in Excel we were
explicitly interested in replicating
that second study the one that looked at
self-efficacy and future usage and
gender we had different software namely
Excel a different population this was a
wide span of adult ages in occupations
all of whom had spreadsheet experience
they were in the Seattle area and once
again they could not be system
developers they couldn't have degrees in
computer science all that kind of stuff
instead of debugging we had them do
maintenance which basically means create
your own bugs and then fix them and we
had a more complex spreadsheet
we focused on the audit tool bar and we
taught some of those features and didn't
teach other features and so it was
pretty much the same experiment design
i've explained to you before
participants could use any excel feature
they wanted they weren't limited in what
they could use and just to overview the
results look at all these X's okay the
pink are the females and the the blue or
the males self-efficacy is a predictor
of success here again we had significant
differences okay yes for the females not
significant for the males although you
can see an upward trend it's not as
pronounced as for the females
self-efficacy is tied to familiar
feature usage all three of these tests
were about that look at these X's once
again for the females these trends were
significant for the males they were not
finally self-efficacy is tied to the
usage of the untaught features this one
we didn't get anything significant
although you can see that the trend
seemed to be more pronounced for the
females but we didn't get significance
on that one so in summary on what we
found out with is there a gender
difference in feature usage the answer
is yes we found it in feature usage we
found it in self-efficacy stuy the
future usage we found it in propensity
to tinker we found it in tinkering sties
to self-efficacy and we found it in
tinkering sties to effectiveness we
found in five different studies a whole
bunch of different populations it's real
ok now this again is something that
we've done only in spreadsheets so if
you all can help us gather data on other
products will know how real it is there
to but now can we fix it yes
we've tried to control for that so in
some cases we in the earlier studies we
had all business students with a
particular minimum amount of spreadsheet
stuff they had to have done and no
computer science and all that kind of
thing in general whenever we do any of
our studies we collect their GPA and
their majors and and the number of years
of programming experience they have if
any because nowadays in high school a
lot of times you get it you know and and
number of years of spreadsheet
experience and we've never explained our
results in those ways but we always look
for it okay so what can we do to fix it
with features now this is much less
mature than the other work so I don't
have nearly as much to tell you about it
but I do have a couple of things to tell
you so in the original prototype of
course we had these these features that
I've shown you and in fact sure enough
they did encourage tinkering we then we
then added whoops we then added where
did I put that oh here we are we then
added these new things so we added a
more expanded version of help and so in
addition to the tooltip which even in
the original version it explains what
people see and it also explains a little
bit about why they might care down here
it was sort of strategy tips what can
you really do about it a little bit more
in-depth explanation so this was version
1 and so we did that and the other thing
we did well we did three things another
thing we did is we added maybe marks so
this means the values right this means
values wrong these two kind of grayed
out ones in the middle will not grayed
out but lighter this one means seems
wrong maybe this one means seemed right
maybe and those all had tooltips yeah
the tooltips it was introduced during
tomorrow I presenter total consistent
throughout experiment was the dude we
did a tutorial at the beginning if
that's what you're asking yes both
groups got the tutorial I think I'm
answering what you asked oh very yeah
they were too discoverable actually yeah
they were very discoverable any time
your mouse spent any amount of time over
anything they came up and and this
little thing here was you know one of
these pulldown things but we taught them
how to do that in the tutorial as well
okay so let's see here so the reason we
introduced these may be marks is these
were intended to be a communication to
those who felt that they might not be
sort of qualified to make the right
wrong judgment you know maybe I'm just
not sure enough of myself just say it's
right or it's wrong and so these you
know seems right maybe seems wrong maybe
we put them there thinking that low
self-efficacy users might be encouraged
by those and use them and what happens
is the the border colors then are just a
little bit more faded out if they make
use of them so that's what we did and we
also had something else testing
scaffolding which I won't talk about
today now the downside of this this
interface is that it was a little bit
more complex and making use of the
features i mean now you've got different
intensities of these border colors to
sort out and you have four instead of
two to choose from and so you know it
was just a little more complex and there
was more visual feedback but there were
some good points one of them was and
this this was just a set of preliminary
transit first so the low confidence
marks over time we began to notice that
the gender gap in male and female usage
seemed smaller than it had been before
and we also began to notice that the
males were using them too although the
females seemed to be using them more
then we changed the interface and
instead of that that pull down tips
thing which we never were able to
implement in not in any very nice way we
added little video snippets instead and
also hypertext as an alternative
that explained strategy and these were
well we were aiming for a minute or less
sometimes we didn't make it but that's a
that's what we did and in a qualitative
study we found out that these were liked
by females and the females all commented
that it improved their confidence in
their ability to solve solve spreadsheet
bugs so then we did a third variant it
had the same nuanced judgments and even
better strategy explanations and we
presented that with a statistical study
at bhcc 08 and in that one we found some
very good things keep in mind these
feature changes I'm telling you about
here these are not big changes okay
we're talking about taking the two
tupple and turning it into a four couple
and we're talking about instead of just
the normal tooltips also having a
hypertext and a little video snippets
feature these are not huge now one of
the things we found is that the females
is that these were very effective
together at helping to close the gender
gap so here we are with tinkering with
the x mark here it was fairly both of
them were pretty small you'll notice
here the in fact the females were
experimenting with those more than the
males in that particular group here
tinkering with the check marks look at
this here we are again with these
control males doing huge amounts of
tinkering then we add you know for the
the group that had the the new interface
it's all nice and even almost flat
furthermore we can see that the females
on both sorts went up when we had the
new interface and the Mail's here it's
almost the same they went up a little
bit but thankfully they didn't exceed
the females and here they went down
remember we like that remember the males
and they're obsessive tinkering okay
it's not so easy to do in the other
interface you have to kind of go you
know click click click I don't know it's
just not quite worth it as much okay and
so this brought them down to the level
we want them to be at which is about the
same level as the females so the females
are going up
we want and the males are going down
which we want
okay so sorry I didn't really explain
this the sea that's control so control
males control field of females so this
first half this is the old environment
and then the second half the treatment
those are the new environment that is
that and timber lists with high cost
computers but more with low-cost
features and do not turning on here
I am so here this is this let's just
look at this graph because it's the most
pronounced with the with the checkmark
tinkering so in the low cost features
the males are tinkering more and then in
the higher cost the the bore the new
interface with the four topple and the
strategy explanations it goes down no
for the males the other way was up yeah
now it's down but I I've switched i
switched left to right maybe I switch no
no i haven't i don't know it's it it did
the right thing okay let's see here i
can show you again later if you want
let's see here okay what about the
difference in self-efficacy because you
may remember that the females had lower
self efficacy than the males too in most
of our studies so we we measure
self-efficacy at the beginning of
studies and at the end and it always
goes down they always no matter male or
female you know they say yeah I'm pretty
good at debugging spreadsheets and then
you give them one to do and at the end
they think well maybe I'm not quite so
good at that after all because yeah
anyway but for the the difference in the
treatment females versus the control
females their self-efficacy went down
less so this is good and furthermore so
you may say well gee why don't we just
tell them they're wonderful and then we
can really just make their self-efficacy
be great but the really good thing is
they were better judges of how their
performance had really been ok so when
we compared their post self-efficacy
judgments against bugs fixed the
treatment females had were much more
aware of how well they had really done
which is good you care because when do
you decide to ship a product or rely on
a spreadsheet it's when you think the
bugs are done so if you're not correct
about when the bugs are done you're
either fiddling around with it way too
long or else fiddling around with it way
too little and these were we got these
out of our questionnaire data but these
were triangulated against post-session
questionnaire answers as well so let's
look at attitudes here
one of the things we can see is that
their overall attitudes with the control
version look at the difference between
the males and the females the females
did not like that original version but
here it's almost the same okay and just
focusing on information which was kind
of focusing on those video snippets and
the the various kinds of help we gave at
the beginning nobody really like them
much and at the end people like them
more but the females especially and
furthermore we can see that for both of
these measures the females wed up and
look at this the male's went up to this
is very cool okay we're trying to fix
the gender gap right we're trying to do
things to enable females to be able to
use this software more effectively and
what we're finding out here is it's
helping everybody okay very cool what's
the scale let's see what were those ah
these were scores I think we these
things were like hurt things and we just
added them all up and so these were just
sort of like hurt score Psalms so yeah
yeah that's what they were yeah you just
you know take 0 to 5 and you know six
questions let's see how many subjects
did we have here this one yeah let's see
here hmm I may not be telling you
everything but we did get a lot yeah I'm
going to have to go back and look at
that for real but I think I think it's
better than it looks there
is it to me it's probably amazing it's
probably a mean i'll have to double
check that um yeah yeah I and I think
possibly aha I know I know I know what
it is okay it's either mean or some I
don't remember which but I know why we
went up to 30 here it's because we went
up to 30 here but you don't actually
have 30 points just available for
talking about information so so the
question is what was the max and I can't
remember but but the females were quite
positive it was quite startling and your
question about how many subjects I think
that that's the study see here we had
close to 60 I can't remember for sure
yeah something like that alright so
we've seen that there is some some
gaining that you can make just by small
changes to features and this is good but
one of the things that that occurred to
us is okay in those new features we had
the maybe marks the the nuanced
judgments and we also had these strategy
videos and what those strategies were
about was what are incorporated what our
features were about which was testing so
we began to wonder well if females maybe
want to go about things some other way
then really promoting testing might not
be going deep enough so we should really
be thinking about what their problem
solving styles and preferences and and
success success stories are really like
from a strategy perspective so so that's
what this third category is about and
we're still fairly new at this too so I
don't have a ton to tell you about but I
can tell you about some things so this
is a this is about a study we did and
published at KY 08 and so we were
interested in end users strategies as
they problem solved with spreadsheets
same as these other studies now the
thing about strategies is there in the
head okay so how are you going to get
that you can't get it from the world so
what we did is we used a lot of
triangulation
so we used participants words about
their strategies and combine that with
electronically logged behaviors about
what they did and did playbacks of that
so that we could understand what they
did in some detail and then we also did
an independent data mining study in
parallel which would also be about what
they did so we used all of those things
and that data mining study was on
different data so we did all of those
things to try to understand what we had
in terms of strategies so we asked
people what kind of strategies they used
and we translated those into one word
codes and they told us about eight
strategies one was data flow and that
was a male strategy as you'll see one
was testing and that was a male strategy
as you'll see one was code inspection
looking at the formulas and that was a
female strategy as you'll see one was
specification checking which was a
female strategy one was color following
now if there are people in here who are
kind of sort of software engineering
people you know don't freak out it's a
color strata following that doesn't
count well it does because if when we
ask them their strategies they said
following the colors then that counted
okay whatever they said was the strategy
was a strategy to do listing was a
female strategy fixing formulas that was
pretty much how it was described as the
strategy that was a female strategy and
finally spatial all good we don't have a
gender on this one okay one out of eight
we didn't find gender differences so
let's look at these accounts the orange
diagonal tells you the the amount for
each particular strategy testing was the
biggest we had 61 participants in this
so this is roughly three-quarters of the
people mentioned something oriented
toward testing talked about fiddling
around with the values to see how they
turned out or various other things they
could have done that we're testing
oriented almost three-quarters also
talked about code inspection or talked
about codes
affection and of those about
three-quarters of them talked about the
other so testing people often also
mention code inspection code inspection
people often also mention testing okay
the next most popular one was
specification checking about half of the
people mentioned that and of those about
two-thirds of them tended to also use
testing and or code inspection so those
are the biggest ones that were mentioned
I don't have time to talk to you about
all of them today but I can tell you
about those three I have time to talk
about those so data flow in the words
one male put it this way systematically
go from the formulas that rely wholly on
data cells progressing to formula that
rely on other formula driven cells and
so on basically he's following the
references a very data flow oriented way
of going about things now so everybody
who we classified as being whoops sorry
everybody who we classified as being
successful who talked about data flow
was male okay we then looked at their
behavior and what we found is that for
males the number of data flow instances
that we could count the actual moving
back through a data flow chain was
positively correlated with bugs fixed
for males not for females look it's just
all over the map okay now there's a
theoretical explanation that we could
apply to this there's been some very
interesting work on information
processing styles from another domain
namely the domain of marketing and there
is a hypothesis that has been borne out
quite repeatedly in other domains called
the selectivity hypothesis and it comes
down to females statistically are more
likely to want comprehensive information
before they start taking action whereas
males are more likely to do something
that you might think of as sort of a
breadth-first sorry a depth first thing
so they take the first promising cue and
sort of follow it up and then if it
doesn't pan out back up and try
thing else okay so there's been a lot of
literature about this and we tend to see
it a lot and that could be the
explanation for this phenomenon here
keep in mind these differences are
statistical right I mean yeah there's no
completely typical male or female so
there's are all just statistical now
there's one feature that's very data
flow oriented and that's those data flow
arrows and we found that for the male's
usage of arrows correlated pause in a
positive direction very significantly to
they're talking about data flow for the
females not so and we also found that
the male's use those arrows almost twice
as often as females okay and we found
this in several other studies as well
okay what about testing another male
strategy so here's the way one male
expressed it after correcting everything
I press help me test so that's a testing
oriented thing and double-check the
values so there's a testing oriented
thing to make sure they work next I
plugged in values okay so very you know
very interested in testing now in terms
of statistics we didn't get gender
differences in in who talked about
testing but remember three quarters of
the people did so it could have just
been a ceiling effect but in behaviors
we found that testing correlated to bugs
fixed not so for females in fact Boyle
boy did it correlate for the males so if
we looked at successful males versus
unsuccessful males what we found was
that value-added successful males did
more of it value at its plus they help
me test scaffolding successful males did
more of it % tested pneus which is you
know how effectively they're using the
features males did more of it for the
females we got nothing absolutely
nothing so then if you compare only the
successful males versus the successful
females we have once again successful
males more successful males more
successful males more okay testing was
definitely a male-oriented strategy
so let's look at code inspection this of
course was examining the formulas
themselves once email said I then looked
at the formulas to see if i could find
mistakes in our environment I've just
sort of shown four versions of the same
cell for some reason but anyway you can
post up the the formula have it sitting
there and you can leave it there and
have others visible at the same time so
it's possible for you to see as many
formulas as you want to plus the values
all at once so that was the facility
they used for code inspection so for the
females when we looked at the number of
instances of people leaving up multiple
formulas at once the successful females
did that significantly more than the
successful males and also when we looked
at the number of formulas they had lying
around in all of the instances we got
the same results successful females
significantly more than successful males
so okay so those are the the findings
that I have to tell you about now in
addition we've started branching out a
little bit in a few other environments
that we've had time to look at so we did
a study in PowerShell actually my
student Valentina did that on an
internship with the PowerShell team and
found consistent results with with the
previous ones that I've just told you
plus three additional strategies because
PowerShell is control flow oriented and
they had a few fewer restrictions as
well on what they could do and also
found suggestive results on exactly how
and when these strategies actually get
used and I guess I didn't mention this
here but we have a paper coming out that
for the about that for the EU d paper or
a conference our hypothesis at the
moment is that when for example when you
look at code inspection that that's tied
to female success in both finding and
actually fixing bugs so so that's what
we're trying to do now is really break
it down and find out what are they using
these strategies for and and how can we
better imagine supporting those we also
have some emerging studies coming out
focusing on strategies in both
a pop fly and going back to excel with a
sense making perspective so those were
sort of analyzing and conducting right
now so that's so the strategy results
overview is we've found eight actually
it's up to 11 now end users debugging
strategies but in the study I told you
about it was 87 had gender differences
the male's the biggest telling points
were with data flow and testing which
were both positive uses of those
strategies for success for females code
inspection to do listing and
specification checking and they also did
something called fixing formulas which
was actually a bad idea now just kind of
thinking about Excel because you know a
lot of this is done in spreadsheets
let's see here data flow okay we know
how to do that in Excel we've got those
arrows you've got that that sort of
color thing you know that you get when
you click in a formula don't have much
in the way of testing but at least we
can fill around with values pretty
easily so you know something how do you
do code inspection in Excel well you
memorize a formula and then you can go
look at some different formula and
memorize that one and then you can look
at some other formula memorize that one
or you can switch to another view and
get all the formulas but now you lose
the values okay so okay so I think
there's some room here okay alright so
let's get back to Ashley remember Ashley
from the very beginning that that person
who whose major changed from graphic
design Dart okay well so what we what we
wonder is whether maybe these were
because of self-efficacy issues maybe
because of motivation issues maybe
because of problem solving style issues
maybe because of information stop
processing style issues all of which
have been shown in many domains to have
gender differences however remember that
those are all statistical right and
there's no mail that's exactly male and
there's no female that's exactly female
and in fact ashley is a male
okay and yet encountered all of these
things because of his particular problem
solving styles so designing for both
genders is about taking down barriers
okay and if we do that it benefits
everyone so that's that I have a whole
bunch of papers and so if you either go
to the uses consortium side and click on
gender just go to my homepage and click
on gender you'll get there but I have a
call to arms so I'm really hoping that
you all can help to contribute to this
work that some of you came in late but I
have these pieces of paper that
hopefully are going around and maybe we
can start another one around and so what
I'm really hoping is that we can get
data on a bunch of Microsoft products
things that you can do as part of your
regular day jobs just just be sure to
collect gender to on whatever studies
are going on perhaps Oh either it with
existing features or if if some of you
already have some ideas about things you
might want to try an old teacher vs new
feature thing would be great and also we
are very very interested in anything we
can get on strategies problem-solving
strategies and what you could contribute
would be interviews surveys user study
statistics whatever you've got you can
analyze it or not and and our hope for
outcomes well we hope there'll be a
technical report of some sort that will
be valuable to Microsoft and
presentations of course inside Microsoft
we're hoping paper out of it too and
hopefully product improvements and so
for those of you who came in late this
is what I'll be focusing on for my three
months stay here that starts toward the
end of March and I'll be working with
Sean ZX Paul and Mary sure winski and
Corey Quinn and Gina van olya on this so
if you don't want to scribble anything
down on that little piece of paper and
would rather just send email to one of
us letting us know what you can
contribute
that would be great because we'd really
like for some data actually be here
pretty early in our stay so that we can
really start tearing into it so yeah
hoping hoping you can contribute what's
your tie in in terms of the research
like computer science teachers of
America and they're trying to create you
know this is a problem this
self-efficacy among girls is a hard nut
to crack you know it's happening in
games etc so csta is looking at three
computer science curriculum what is the
sort of modeling problem solid
I'm thinking that you need to start like
in the first rate or fifth grade to
create the pipeline and have you been
involved in are you seeing any good
stuff happening because by the time your
attending college students and your site
the one right okay so i have a yes and a
no for you to answer that question the
no part is i'm not really directly
involved in that but the yes part is i'm
i'm very aware of that going on and i
can tell you if you don't already know
about it about a great resource to
connect with on kind of the state of the
art in that area and that's NC wit okay
so those of you who haven't heard of
that national center for women and
technology is this wonderful
organization whose mission is to collect
what everybody around the country is
trying to do and to try to turn it into
a science instead of people just all
kind of hacking away in independently
coming up with solutions that maybe
don't work or maybe do so NC witness is
great in that area we have been studying
adults college students and post college
students because well i guess for a for
more than one reason but one of them is
we think if we don't document and
understand the effect the way it is
among today's adults we're going to have
to wait a really long time before we
start removing this glass ceiling so you
know they're there are lots of people
age you know 18 270 who are facing this
already so so that's the piece of the
pie we've tried to break off and then of
course we're focusing on the software
itself but i do think that there are big
implications for the way software that
k-12 students are using should change
too but but we haven't focused on it yes
rules of thumb for software design that
avoid this style of approach because it
fits
main center court
I mean it sounds like you've got very
kind of specific information about the
scenario is you're in the tests on
whatever yeah now generalize that you
well um here's another yes and no for
you so we we haven't progressed to the
point of actual guidelines because our
research is too early and that's one of
the reasons why we want to generalize it
and get data from you all because we
think we might be able to get there but
but I do have two hypotheses based on
the prototype work we've done so far and
one of them is nuanced interfaces so if
you're asking somebody to take a stand
it's right it's wrong okay maybe that's
not the right thing and so this nuanced
interface thing not only did it help to
close the gender gap in our study but
also it turned it just it's just better
I mean the men we're using it to and you
think about it there's more information
there now instead of saying it's right
or it's wrong if there were something
you weren't quite so sure of and then
you know you'd make some changes in the
spreadsheet still isn't right you know
which ones to come back to so by two so
by looking at the barriers for one group
what we've done here is come up with
something that's better so what I might
suggest is that if there's a feature in
the product you have that asks for some
sort of judgment or perhaps dogmatic
stand and you give some nuances to it
that would be worth trying out trying
some before after comparisons the other
one I have really less information about
and so the other thing we've tried is
this strategy thing which is
explanations that are not about the
features but about the approach and most
software help doesn't have that some
sort of online documentation help does
but now it's this big thing you have to
read as opposed to little snippet II
low-cost things that you can get your
hands on right away so we do have you
know you know a mounting body of
evidence that that seems to help but but
all of that were those two things that
we've tried are still fairly early in
the game so I would hesitate to actually
call them
guidelines at this point but they're
things you can try yes sort of follow up
on that question man aligning with the
selectivity hypothesis does that not
apply to
is it because you've entered into the
experience you then saw health and
presented with this volume of support
the selectivity hypothesis not applied
that because that's providing a fuller
picture rather than an incidental or
nuanced here as me so the way we
implemented our strategy approach was
also add need as needed and so for
example instead of saying everybody's
got to read this stuff what the way we
implemented it is in the tooltip there's
a button you can click that says either
show me or tell me and then that causes
that other thing to come up so I don't
recall our statistically measuring
whether the females actually asked for
it more we've seen that qualitatively
but instances of help the show me and
tell me that's demonstrative versus area
right yes and some people learn better
one way and some the other but one
reason we really thought it was
important to have a video version
besides the learning differences is that
self-efficacy theory says that one way
to boost your self efficacy is if you
see someone with whom you identify
succeeding at the same task and so in
those little video snippets I don't know
if you noticed but we have a male and a
female working together on it and in one
of our qualitative studies it was a
think-aloud and we were doing we were
videotaping and we went back and looked
at it and at that time the female
actress with neeraj yahoo a few of you
may know and every time she said
something the subject smiled so she was
definitely identifying with her do you
do
the way the videos were constructed or
was it just simply um I wish I could say
that it did but it didn't yeah so yeah
and and we're still iterating on those
two so it's quite possible that that
would have been an improvement to it
even more but I think what you were
originally asking about was how that
related to the selectivity hypothesis
and and intuitively we thought that that
the females would probably ask for more
information but as i said i'm not sure
that we've measured that statistically
we have seen it qualitatively but i'm
not sure if we've actually tried to see
whether that's true in the numbers but
it seems to satisfy the ones who seem to
want that more information ask another
follow-up question for drugs who the
judgment yeah so
my role at microsoft is from manager for
user experience fuzzy web and we're
implementing but
ability for people to basically rate the
dollar she's being considered so we're
having discussion right now whether a
graduated scale of one to five stars
mm-hmm what's on ms library or a
dichotomous which is like a day or so
these other sites use yes thumbs up
thumbs down hmmm you're an advocate of
providing regardless gender I graduated
scale mmhmm yeah and we haven't
personally looked into this one but
probably this literature that says that
females are more likely to be polite
about these things too so if you have a
thumbs up thumbs down you know more
people are going to do the sums up
probably if they're females this is my
guess Oh time to fix them another
brother uh-huh right exactly yes Thanks
a personal credibility what your users
mentioning is it when I did a lot of
research
one of my regular routine questions that
I ask you about manage
I asked them to
mention a soft virtual any product that
they had use that because
the product was by far most common
dimension was himself so I found it I
want to fit that was until you have you
chose that one of this particular box by
far so as I mentioned most commonly as
being right and i think it's not ironic
because the thing is maybe that just
turned out to be a fantastic example of
a male-oriented tool that's out there
and so it may be gave us the magnifying
glass we needed to really see the
phenomenon we'll see how widespread it
turns out to be
haha yeah onion point being it it was in
the psychological research there's quite
a lot of
the way they women approach problems the
way the window moving up then approached
the world
more environmental position whereas men
tend to be approaching things again not
a more kind of caste based basically
basis or
so that you know I women
entire environment around a specific
thing that they're doing uh-huh whereas
men are more likely to be focusing on
specific I how do i achieve this goal
learn much more synchronous underscores
when they're in more light
contents that relates to the terms that
you are seeing here is I think it could
well and we've seen we've seen some
literature that sort of kind of alludes
to that but I think we maybe haven't
read all the right papers that we should
so if you actually have some references
that you can contribute that would that
would be super yeah I know we won't be
able to read all of it but I you know
already we've been trying to keep our
finger on you know something like five
different domains as we try to gather
the theories that are really relevant
here but we're always looking for for
really important things we've missed and
it sounds like we could do some reading
there so that would be great in this
line of research it was using all these
portals one thing that we included in
our general thinking about this that you
guys might want
as use of social media tool is kind of
like the blog sites for example Clinton
or maybe they ask an expert option and
then it things of that nature thinking
about you
social support yes yeah I would think so
too and we haven't you know we tried to
focus on just one sort of style because
you know that way we could really try to
get some data and compare it but you
know if there are people working on that
sort of tool that would be so great
because we do strongly suspect that that
that could make a big difference so yeah
I see another hand somewhere maybe not